i want to talk about a whole lot of red
look there's a lot of artists and albums
out there that i could talk about but
playboy guardian whole lot of red
deserve a discussion i know opinions on
this one are pretty split so i'm going
to do my part to just explain how i got
to where i am and maybe give you a hint
on how you could get there too my
history with playboy cardi is
interesting to say the least
my little brother recommended died lit
to me back in 2018 and i gotta say it
was one of the worst things i'd ever
heard i was frankly astounded i'd never
imagined that
my own brother would be listening to
this kind of garbage the beats were
pretty good but the lyrics were
indecipherable and so repetitive that i
i thought this guy maybe had brain
damage i remember thinking and declaring
at the time that flatbed freestyle was
one of the worst songs i'd ever heard in
that year or any year and
then
yeah that's been hard to shake i think i
liked one song i think it was a song
with uzi cause it seemed like it had a
melody that i could follow i gotta tell
my bestie someone call my bestie and of
course i told my brother my reaction and
he told me i was a hater and that i
didn't understand it and i don't like
when people tell me that because i like
to think i can understand things but it
would turn out that he was right
yo
what what you're gonna have on my call
something happened in the years that
followed that experience and a lot of it
was memes take back what you said about
my mom
i'll kill you
i'd see these meme videos posted on
twitter instagram or whatever using
playboy cardi songs and i didn't know
that hearing it
man i love the memes and the music just
fit so well and i found myself
unknowingly listening to playboy cardi
over and over again
[Music]
through this process with the memes you
know i realized that
yeah there was something there obviously
lyrics were beside the point when i paid
attention to them on the first listen
that's why i hated the album more
important was the headspace that it put
me in the headspace of the music put me
in the beats are fun you know they
envelop you and they transport you to
this place where nothing makes any sense
and that's okay
i compare becoming a fan of playboy
cardi to breaking a glow stick the glow
stick doesn't work unless you break it
you still have to break it though
something has to snap and yeah in my
brain and in anybody else's brain i
think when you're first presented with
play by cardi it does not work but at
some point along the line something
might snap and then suddenly it all
makes sense
yeah so now after all the memes had come
around i found that maybe there were
four or five songs on dialett that i
really loved and i was like dang i have
to i have to rethink this album but it
wasn't too long after that point for me
that december 25th of 2020 rolled around
a day that i think should live in infamy
as the red christmas
i'm a guy who's on twitter and the
reaction initially on twitter was crazy
a lot of people trying to get hashtags
going like whole lot of mid whole lot of
skips and yeah i get it people hated
this album and then you had a small
corner of people proclaiming it an
instant classic i do enjoy when that
polarity exists
and at this point i wonder if those
people screaming instant classic we're
all that crazy
no i don't know maybe they were still
crazy for me though initial reaction to
this album i liked a handful of songs as
i went through this album there was a
lot that was rough and i was honestly
motivated to skip and thinking this is
not that good by the time i reach the
end though the final track feel like
dying samples bony bear
and i feel like that that in itself
shocked me and stopped me in my tracks
and i realized uh i gotta listen to the
whole album again
so i listened to it a second time and
maybe one or two more songs that i liked
and then i just kind of stopped
listening to it the timeline after that
point is kind of odd and hard to
remember but i know that there were
various points when i just decided to
put this on again just to give it a try
like i said there were a few songs that
i liked so i figured why not just try
the whole album again i tried it on a
drive here and there i tried it at the
gym i tried it while i was gaming and
sure enough it felt like it started to
grow on me more with each listen wake up
[Music]
i took a bit of a gamble buying the
album on vinyl because i wasn't sure if
i truly love it but by the time i got it
on wax and threw it on the turntable i
have to say i realized i made the best
decision i don't know what it is man it
just completely turned around for me
where now i like pretty much every
single song there are obviously some
that are better than others and there's
at least one song that i don't like and
that's t-nex with future but man the
rest of it is enjoyable and the whole
thing is pretty cohesive i can throw
this on in any context and just kind of
sit and listen to the entire album and i
have to say that the final run of the
album starting with the track place
[Music]
if you don't like this album start there
just listen to that as like a mini ep
it'd be dangerous for me to say that
that run is perfect but it's pretty
close
[Music]
and one thing that's interesting about a
whole lot of red is that when i do start
to listen to the lyrics i find myself
having a great time
is funny i don't know if he's trying to
be but he's funny they thought i was gay
of course for the most part it's very
simple and not a whole lot to unravel
but the one-liners get members
[Music]
also the other day for some reason i
thought that playboy cardi and kurt vile
are kind of similar i say that because
they both operate in these genres but
sort of outside the boundaries of what's
normally acceptable you know kirk vial
is a singer-songwriter working in the
rock genre but his songs are long and
meandering and just kind of stoner jam
sessions that a lot of people probably
wouldn't like
his lyrics are kind of free associative
just mundane everyday stuff for a lot of
people that's probably not enough in the
rock music that they're looking for
maybe it's too far outside the lines and
the same can be said for playboy cardi
you know play bacardi is a hip-hop
artist and hip-hop is a genre that loves
looking back on the past and operating
in you know certain styles but he
removes lyricism which is a core
component of hip-hop and focuses instead
on vibes whatever that means yeah it's
gonna upset people and disrupt things
but hey for some people it's gonna click
actually there's one other thing i
forgot to mention i remembered this
while i was editing so obviously cardi's
going for this blood red aesthetic and
there's talk of what seems to be
vampires right he uses the word vamp a
lot on the album you got king vamp
vampantham but what i don't see a lot of
people talk about is that the term
vamping has a different meaning in music
vamping has to do with repetition of
some short musical phrase does that not
sound familiar because i've always had a
soft spot a repetition
does playboy cardi's music not reek of
repetition when he says that he's the
king vamp is he talking about his
ability to vamp just something to think
about just throwing it out there so yeah
i found myself
middle to end of 2021 loving playboy
cardi's whole lot of red a bit too late
for me to put it in my own personal list
of favorite albums of 2020 and then
oddly enough by the end of 2021 i saw
publications like pitchfork putting a
whole lot of red in their year-end lists
for 2021. um hello is that is that
allowed that sounds illegal the album
came out in 2020. obviously i don't like
that for me that's a rule that i have
for myself i'm not gonna cross those
boundaries just because i came to
something late so i was too late to put
it in 2020
i cannot technically put it in 21.
where does it go the truth of the matter
is it's not going anywhere this whole
year-end jam the rush to put it into one
list or the lag behind and put it in
another it taught me a lesson in
appreciation the thing about art is it's
forever i feel like in music especially
everybody wants to be early right we all
listen to the albums right when they
come out and there's nothing wrong with
that but i do think the rush to be early
is less useful sometimes especially with
albums like this that are gonna shock
you and not connect with you on one
listen who cares if you're not early or
on time what matters is that you just
show up it's not going anywhere there's
a great instance of tyler the creator
explaining this to a fan who would ask
for the old tyler his response was what
are you on punishment or something why
can't you listen to it it's still there
the music is always going to be there
it's not about when you get there but
just that you get there artists progress
their music progresses but we can always
go back and listen to albums as a
snapshot of where they were and where we
were i imagine there's some people
watching this video that don't like
playboy cardi and there's probably a lot
of people that even after this video
aren't going to like playboy cardi and
that's okay the other thing about art is
that it's subjective and it's not going
to be for everybody if you hate it all i
ask is that you understand why maybe
you're like i was and you're focusing on
lyrics and looking for a rap album in
the traditional sense which that's not
what you're getting so
stop looking but i also don't think you
need to force yourself to keep up you
know there's so many artists out there
and i hear this all the time where
somebody says they listen to an album
15 20 times and it finally clicked i
think few if any of us have that kind of
patience and if you don't don't push
yourself too hard but if you do have
some patience and you do have some time
on your hands and you don't think that
you like or understand whole lot of red
give it another shot maybe don't pay as
much attention maybe throw it on while
you're doing something else i feel like
that in itself is a sin but try it you
might still hate it that's okay but
maybe your glow stick will break and
suddenly you'll find that you are insane
and you do enjoy it like me but you know
what it's never too late and it's never
too
[Music]
much never too much